hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the Grantchester rapid event
it's Fabiano cora wanna with the white
piece against Alexander Greece shook and
well it's really exciting him we don't
have a photo of the matchup as it it
like I said it's a game of the final
round so perhaps they still haven't
uploaded the photos but we do have a
nice close-up of Alexander we shook so
let's just enjoy that for a second there
you have it don't know it's if it's from
round nine or maybe it's from round
seven hard to say if we can you know
figure it out from anything but as he
looks very refreshed here I would say
it's maybe from round seven not from
round nine but still hard to say so
there you have it now let's enjoy the
game Korona has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 with E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 sorry about that
we have Bishop to c4 and Bishop to c5 so
the Italian game is on the board and I
don't need to mention that the Evans
gambit before was not playing in this
game but I will mention that I am
preparing a very nice Evans game gambit
game very soon for it for you so C 3 we
have Knight to f6 and now comes d3 we
have d6 for Fabiano castles with a6
making room for the bishop on 87 and now
a for preparing before to grab more
space on the Queen side Bishop black day
7 and now rook to e1 and now as we've
been covering a lot of a-tellin games
lately we always mentioned that 94 isn't
really doing anything rookie - perfectly
the defense DF - pawn so with castles
here by Grichuk and now h3 not allowing
Bishop to g4 and weave Bishop to e6 now
by chrish hook and now
Fabi captures with Bishop captures pawn
captures and now b4 Knights to h5 going
after that f4 square as similar like
we've analysed during the OtterBox Nova
championship in the game bits between
Roxy Marshall Grove and ding Liron we've
looked a - as you have the rook here the
Queen is probably coming over to f6 the
other group will also join f8 when this
rook moves the bishop also attacks f2 so
you will need all the additional
the defenders of the f2 square as
possible and now comes Queen t8 in the
game we mentioned Maxima share log
reverses England Queen to f6 was played
by ding in the altar box no championship
this year at that game ended in a draw
but here we have Queen to d8 and this is
a new move that has never been played
before interestingly dings Queen to f6
is the engine stop recommendation
whereas Queen to e8 is the engine second
recommendation and it's often something
that grandmasters try you know to get
each other out of preparation not to
play the absolute engine favorite but
maybe the second or the third engines
favorite which doesn't really compromise
your position so there's a better chance
that your opponent doesn't know the
reply by heart so here a completely new
position now it's a fob Eastern with
Knights to a3 the knight now prepares to
jump over to c4 and with Knight to f4 so
here you could wait for Queen to g6 and
only then capture the night but as Queen
to g6 is definitely gonna be played you
want to get to this rook to f6 bring
this rope over to f8 you might as well
capture it immediately and this is what
Bobby does with Bishop captures and now
rook captures pawn captures does fix
your pawn structure but it takes away
control from black of the d4 square and
it's something you don't want to give up
as the dis lights were this dark square
bishop is just a monster and you don't
want to allow d4 so by capturing with
the rook you keep an eye on the d4
square with night the C for now and here
comes Queen to g6 already threatening
rook to f8 and then maybe some rook
captures an f3 action
we have b5 by Fabi and Grisha ignores
the threat with rook a to f8 so now what
do you get if you go for this line
Bishop captures then black captures on
f3 and you don't have any sort of a
mating attack or anything but black will
you know
now come on top after all of the
exchange it's 93 you have to block the
dark squared Bishop Bishop captures on
e3
rook captured sorry rook captures rook
captures and now after F captures you're
gonna capture on these on c6 you're
going to be up
and well blacks position is is just a
little bit better here now even though
we do have this very weird bone
structure in the center I'm not sure
I've ever seen anything like that but
okay after rook a to f8 Bobby of course
doesn't know all this we have rook c2 d2
getting another defender here and now
comes Knight to e7
with d4 by white and now comes Queen to
f6 so now when you have this rook Queen
rook battery piling up on the f2 pawn
also the bishop here is attack on the f2
point it doesn't seem all that likely
that this night will ever move from here
we have D captures on e5 and now D
captures on e5 again you want to keep an
eye on the d4 square you don't want to
allow it blocked somehow anytime soon
with B captures an e6b captures on a6
and now Queen to e2
I'm getting more defenders here and now
the roof to f1 is the idea with a 5 as
also the Queen attacks d6 pawn so not
sure if you know capturing this would be
a good idea as you are under siege but
just in case you know it comes up later
get to that point to safety with group 2
F 1 and now Grichuk starts an all-out
attack with g5 preparing g4 and here
Knight to c4 biphobia a nice attack on
the FF 1 and also a double attack on the
e5 pawn and here Grisha plays Knight to
g6 he defends the e5 pawn but also just
straight out g4 was also possible H
captures and only then Knight to g6 is
one way to play it and then you can you
know maybe capture with the rook and
continue the game in this fashion but ok
we have nice to g6 it's a rapid game and
then now nice to H 2 now with the Queen
end with the night the the push of the
g1 is prevented we have Queen back to g7
and now comes Queen to d3 with Knights
to h4 now with
the path has been cleared for the pond
to be pushed and maybe even supported
with h5 and hear the engines given nice
captures on a5 as better for white and
they say that g4 is really not a problem
for black but who would really capture a
point in a situation like this so you
know if you're not really a poem grabber
you're not gonna go for this because g4
h capture sin g4 and now after Queen to
f7 Queen to g3 just defends everything
and you know you you will be able to
fend off the attack
but after Knight h4 Fabiano played
nights to g4 and he'll out Grichuk well
a lot of momentum for the price of this
ePHI porn with h5 now he will have nice
support for his g4 push we have night G
captures on e5 and now g4 with H
captures H captures and now Fabi blocks
any further immense advancements with
Queen to g3 but now comes Queen to g5 so
what do you play here we have rook to a
2 and now came to g7 with Knights to d3
attacking the rook here and now would
you play here Grisha played night for to
f6 also possible is Knight to f3 sorry
rook to f3 but rook to a3 is forcing a
draw because here after G captures and
Knight captures with check King to g2
you get a knight to h4 check and now you
can repeat this neither future tonight a
check gesture or you can go King to h1
but then it's a different kind of draw
it's a rook f3 and then after Queen e5
check you get a trade of Queens and now
rook h3 is a force draw kim jiwon a ruby
g3 check you cannot capture due to the
well nice pin here
King h1 check check check check and
that's a that's a threefold repetition
grow so Grisha doesn't go for this he
goes a rook to f6 he wants to keep the
the attack live and here a best idea for
Caruana is rook b1 he won't he he needs
to prepare this rook to b7 move as the
Queen already attacks the c7 point but
here
Khurana decided that it was okay to grab
a bone so he didn't like this capture
but he does like this capture
as it comes with check so Queen captures
on c7 with rook to f7 attacking the
Queen and now Queen to e5 with Queen to
h6 now creating some deadly threats
knife to f3 is one such threat that
would force open the G file so Queen
back to g3 but now it doesn't work here
Grisha just played a very nice move King
to f8 is possible but King to h8 even
better he's now just freeing the the G
file for the Rose and now there really
isn't all that much you can do Knight to
f3 is the threat and I don't even I
don't even have a position to ask you to
pause the video in as Knight f3 is just
unavoidable
you could try Queen h2 or something like
that but it doesn't work still Knight
checks and the Queen trader doesn't help
you even if Queen captures rook captures
you don't have a good reply to Ruby g7
mate because you're rockin e2 is also
hanging and it doesn't help you if you
move the rook create some room for a
king is still room g7 check King f1 and
of course you ignore the rook rook h1 is
mate
so here Bobby tried rook the b2 but it
doesn't help nice to f3 check with G
captures on f3 g captures on f3 and now
there's no defense against room g7 the
queen is lost
Fabiano played looked roof - f - B 1 and
now rook to g7
just travel the Queen Queen captures we
have Queen captures with check came to
f1 and now Greece you just continues in
in a strong fashion we have rope to h6
threatening mate in one
so King to e1 and now ok we can use this
as a post pause the video moment pause
the video and find a forced mate in
three it's a very very nice sequence so
you know feel free to do it for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations of course you are an
excellent major in 3 and for those of
you who just won't enjoy it show Queen
characters on c3 check with King to d1
and now well you can either capture the
night but even better is not better but
maybe just nicer for me rook h1 Charak
Knight blocks and now this rook captures
anyone is checkmate
Bobby of course did not
wait for this after Queen captures on c3
if I will resign the game and a very
nice victory for Alexandria in the final
round of the Paris rapid event so the
rapid event is now over I will not
mention the standings as I'm planning to
show another video tomorrow morning then
we're gonna check out the standings but
tomorrow I believe I believe there is no
rest date tomorrow the blade starts so
we're gonna enjoy some nice and bliss
games in Paris yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it really interesting
Fabi didn't go for this point capture
when it was possible but he went for
this pawn capture and then it was no
longer possible unfortunately for him
but yeah I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Michael Larson and
pretty much Phil going for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos ER
think of for watching and I will see
soon continuing what we are currently
doing of course checking off your
suggestions and so on and so on
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day